if you laugh life is what oh well here's
I live by laugh love acceptance
understanding gratitude and honesty and
that's basically I believe that laughing
is what will save your mind and it's
also great ab work like singing and
acceptance is that where you basically
pick what's important to you and you
accept what you can't change and then of
course you go and change what you can
that you can't accept and understanding
I find would take a lot of the hatred
out of what's going on today with
society people understand the concept of
like cognitive dissonance which makes a
lot of people they're not open to
discussion and to changing their
paradigm and what they do is they defend
and push away but if you understand
what's happening I know insecure angry
people are easy to brainwash and it's a
lot harder to convince someone that
they've been fooled than to fool them so
if you understand that you're less
likely to be as angry when you're
dealing with what's happening today and
gratitude is remembering that we could
be dead I always think of Carrie Fisher
went through my drug rehab decades ago
like 20 years ago or something and she
was exactly my age and I know that she
didn't stay sober she just couldn't and
I always think about that could have
been me if I'd still still be doing a
coke and and then I also think about how
I never killed anyone
I drove drunk a lot cuz like I said you
know help me merge and I didn't want to
I thought only bad people
drove under the influence but then I
became one and again that was you know a
war inside me so I drank more but then I
you know I was able to actually get home
I'd always be shocked how my car was
parked and I I'm so I on days so they're
really hard for me now I think about
that that I never killed anyone because
I have being a codependent Canadian I'd
never get over that I mean and neither
would they or their families so so just
being grateful that I'm not an alcoholic
and an addict and destroying my life and
others and honesty I have to be honest
with myself or else I am I'll really
blow it
I'll get nervous and anxious if I try to
bury red flags they will be buried up my
butt and that hurts and so I've got yeah
I've got to look at them before they go
up there okay so let's laugh right
[Laughter]
you